Conversations are often dominated by the
loudest person.
And this is worse if you're naturally
quiet. It's getting cut off can kill
your confidence and make it tough to
connect with other people. But there is
good news. You do not need to be loud to
command respect and prevent people from
speaking over you. In fact, there are
just four simple things that will make
people eagerly listen to you even if
you're quiet. First, when you start
speaking, you will capture far more
attention if you pre-frame it with a
hype line. This is a sentence that tells
everyone you're about to share something
good and it looks like this. You were
talking about NYU, your time at NYU?
This is my favorite Adam Sandler story.
This is a really fun one. I'm packed up
now. I've graduated. You should, you
know, have a conversation with him and
suss it out.
And I'll never forget, you know, meeting
him in New York. A good hype line
signals that what's coming is absolutely
worth listening to. It buys you time
even if your story starts off slow. And
an extremely powerful one for almost any
situation is, "Oh, you're going to love
this." Just make sure that you're
relating the story back to the people
you're speaking with so they have reason
to love it. Matthew McConaughey does
this very well in a story that he told
on the Graham Norton Show.
>> And saying no to it
I think sent a little invisible message
to Hollywood, "Oh, McConaughey is not
bluffing." We're talking about not
flinching. That's permission. Oh, he's
playing offense. The offers came in that
I was looking for. They would not have
come in if I wouldn't have unbranded for
that 20 months. All right. Now, Dwayne,
you didn't have to unbrand. You had
enough steam going. I can make whatever
choice I want.
>> And of course, he started that story
with the unique but very solid hype
line.
>> Cuz I had that 4:00 a.m. in my solitude
on my own truth that hit me.
It lands like a butterfly and strikes
like a lightning bolt the same time.
That truth that you go, "Okay, tomorrow
when the sun comes up and I'm back in
the masses and all of the world's coming
at me and all those offers, I need to
remember this truth."
>> Now, once you have people's attention,
you want to keep it with gravity pauses.
These are moments of silence that draw
people in rather than inviting them to
interrupt. The problem with regular
pauses is that people can sometimes use
them as an opportunity to jump in and
cut you off. It's a weird one.
>> Not quite.
But thank you. I'm sure I'm going to
remember that for the rest of my life.
Well, at least he's a handsome guy, I
guess.
>> then he said, "So then So then he said
He stopped me and he's like, 'Joey
Lawrence?'" I said, "No. No, thank you.
No." If you want to make these pauses
have gravity so that people lean in, you
can do two things. First, hold eye
contact through the pause. You can watch
how that draws people in like crazy.
>> I don't like visiting jail. I don't like
that type of perception. So, I I said I
I told my pops I I I can't come see you
cuz I see you as a king.
But I wrote him
I wrote him You may also have noticed
that Jamie raises his hand when he
pauses in sort of an I'm not finished
gesture. This is also a great example of
our third point, which is a gravity
gesture. You can watch Zendaya do
something similar. So, we're doing this
this this this thing where I'm basically
up in the air and I spin down and I get
caught and I heard a fart.
Now, wait.
>> We all heard the fart.
These are body language cues that pull
people in. Notice how in this video
Keanu was able to create a huge pull of
attention without raising his voice. I
am not here
without working with such talented,
beautiful
artists and people.
Now, we just did a video with more
detail on body language, but in short,
open palms, elbows off your sides, and
bonus points for acting out the things
that you're saying almost like you're
playing charades. It's almost I look at
it like a record and you're building
grooves into the record. So, once you
put the the note on the record, your
brain and your mouth,
because you've done it so many times,
just play the record. These are
especially powerful when you're public
speaking. It helps people in the back
stay connected and it gives your hand
something to do, which cuts down on
nervous fidgeting. Now, even if you
master every one of these techniques,
there will still be people who cut you
off. So, when that happens, there's one
thing that you generally want to do and
that is to finish your sentence before
yielding the floor. Most people's
instinct when someone jumps in is to
stop talking. But if you instantly stop
to let that other person speak, it can
come across like you don't value what
you have to say. And you get that sense
in this clip of Jaden as he gives up on
trying to be heard. But yeah, no, that
is something. Do you guys
>> That'll get you really humble. How does
that keep you humble?
>> Well, because people sort of often ask,
you know, like
>> You can contrast that with Russell Brand
in this next clip. Notice that he
doesn't yell or rush to finish. He just
continues his sentence at his normal
pace until he completes the thought. I
wouldn't do that. I'm going to dis-
disrespect your program. Okay, no, no.
You didn't ask to see your
fellow Englishwoman, so I felt obliged.
To be clear, making sure that you finish
your sentence is a general rule of
thumb. You do not need to be obsessive
over it or turn it into a dominance
game. Sometimes it's totally fine to get
interrupted, respond, and keep rolling
as Matthew McConaughey does later in the
story that we'd seen earlier. But I
ultimately said no.
That must be so hard to say no. It was,
but
it Saying no to it, I think sent a
little invisible message to Hollywood.
So, very simple. Lead with a hype line,
use gravity pauses and gestures, and
finish your sentence when someone tries
to interrupt you, and all of that will
make it happen way less often. And if
you are interested in mastering other
charismatic skills like effective
storytelling, radiating confidence, and
reliably making great first impressions,
you may want to join Charisma
University. It's our 30-day program to
help max out your confidence and
charisma. And here's what just a few of
the students have said after a few days
inside the course. I don't even have a
bachelor diploma. Yet they want me to
fill this position. And when I asked
why, this was the answer. You have great
social skills, which is rare for an
engineer. You can think quickly on your
feet and you are open and self-assured
in your demeanor. Thank you so much for
all that you have taught me. You have
truly changed my life because without
Charisma University, I wouldn't have
qualified for that position in a million
lifetimes. Or check out this student's
experience with dating. Loving the
course. I've liked a girl for over a
year now, but never thought much of it
because I thought she was just too
pretty. Took your lessons, gave things a
shot, and now we are dating. And try
this one out for friendship.
>> It has been truly incredible. I have
instantly had results that seemed
insane. So many more meaningful
conversations. My friendships have
improved and my interactions with total
strangers are a new, exciting,
fulfilling thing. I want to recommend
this to everyone. This should be in our
basic education system. Now, the course
comes with a full money-back guarantee
so there's no risk to you trying. There
are thousands of people that have
improved their lives with Charisma
University and I would love for you to
do the same. Either way, I hope that
this video has helped you and I look
forward to seeing you in the next one.